ich habe einfach geträumt
dass ich in einem Fußballverein war und
ein Tor schießen wollte
und
sich der Torwart dann in den Esel
verwandelt hat
[Musik]
und damit herzlich willkommen heute
endlich mal wieder zum neuen Vlog auf
meinem YouTube-Kanal meine Damen und
Herren schreibt mir mal bitte in die
Kommentare wie oft ihr euch in der Woche
die Haare wascht ich jeden Tag Stories
von Freundinnen die so sagen
zwei Flaschen
zwei Lappen ich liebe mein neues
Wohnzimmer
hier unten ne da vorne scheint ein
bisschen die Sonne rein hier vorne das
ist auch so ein bisschen die zockerecke
weil hier drin das Playstation und sowas
alles ich habe mir unten nach außen
Kühlschrank geholt und so die Sache ist
allerdings wo ich trotzdem die meiste
Zeit verbringen ist tatsächlich hier
da passt allerdings tatsächlich auch
ganz gut zu mir denn ich bin beschissen
also wie mein content
vielleicht heute soll es allerdings
genau um diesen beschissenen Content von
mir gehen meine Damen und Herren denn
ich mache mal wieder einen Blog
wir noch gar nicht erkennen konntet
wahrscheinlicher zum Frühstück ne man
braucht einfach nur Milch und
Haferflocken und wenn man pimpen will
noch so ein bisschen Früchte Obst und
Honig und so aber es schmeckt brutal ein
bisschen durchwühlt aus und wie Kotze
aber wir haben hier Bären und
Weintrauben und testest
eigentlich ein Thema das heutigen Blocks
meine Damen und Herren denn ich fahre
natürlich nicht ohne Grund gleich nach
Hamburg habe ich das überhaupt schon
gesagt als nicht ich fahre nach Hamburg
hier
ich dachte es passt weil wenn Logo ist
auch ein zwei Diener wenn es euch mal
hier ein
relativ ähnlich aber darum soll es auch
nicht gehen meine Damen und Herren denn
gleich kommt ein Kollege zu mir der
wollte eigentlich schon vor ich habe
keine Uhr an Sirio wollte eigentlich
schon
immer wenn ich das sage geht mein Handy
ne die Person dessen Name nicht genannt
werden darf wegen meinem oh mein Gott
das ist ein Kranker Übergang meine Damen
und hält ihn blocky geht es um Moment
kommt hier eine Menge Staub raus
ihr alle logischerweise
selbstverständlich mitbekommen habt habe
ich ja in den letzten Tagen eine Menge
auf meinem Twitch account at laserluca
livestreamt unter anderem auch Hogwarts
Legacy das neue Spiel von Warner Bros
und die Jungs und Mädels von Hogwarts
Legacy haben meine Streams gesehen und
haben gesagt Luca wir sehen hier dass du
ein riesiger Fan bist von Hogwarts in
einem drumherum
Store und haben mir ein cooles Event
kommen auch gerne rum bringen Kollegen
mit der immer noch nicht da ist dazu
geht in 30 Minuten
hallo Damen und Herren hier seht ihr die
Kirsche von Köln
mach Foto so wie ich den halte wie soll
Foto machen
[Musik]
in meiner Butze hier in Hamburg hier ist
tatsächlich absolut gar nichts mehr am
Start ich habe auf jeden Fall in den
letzten drei vier Tagen schon locker 12
Stunden Hogwarts Legacy gezockt von
daher kann ich euch schon ein bisschen
was darüber erzählen denn ihr startet
tatsächlich direkt in die fünfte Klasse
mit eurem eigenes erstellten Charakter
das ist eine komplette riesige Open
World das heißt Sie können nicht nur
Hogwarts entdecken sondern auch hogs.med
oder lowerbox dann kann sich unter
anderem in dem Spiel auch sein eigenes
Haus auswählen also ob er jetzt
Gryffindor sein wollt hufel Paaren ich
habe mich für Gryffindor entschieden
wir gehen jetzt auf jeden Fall zu
eventuell
[Musik]
also das hier sind die Kameras die hier
beim Event nutzen und mit dieser Kamera
finde ich meine Box Liebe korrekt und
sehr einfach Kaugummis an die Sätze die
ihr jetzt gleich hört kommen einfach von
einem Harry Potter Synchronsprecher den
wir auch hier getroffen haben sag mal
ein paar Sätze ihr könntet in den
Kommentaren raten welche Personen
gesprochen
die schaffen mich ja okay den
spruchlose Mix übrigens auch da
ist übrigens Borussia Dortmund Fanshop
spielt ja Ende des 19 Jahrhunderts ne
ich liebe halt so dieses Universum so
sich dann irgendwie so so schnell
schnell so 20 30 Minuten so das finde
Sachen nicht gerecht sondern auch die
Musik und so anguckst ne wenn du einfach
so checkst es ist Open World ja was ich
eh schon immer so unfassbar geil finde
und einfach dann auch in Kombination der
Grafik plus du hast ja auch nicht jetzt
irgendwie hier in Hogwarts ist jetzt
irgendwie siehst ja schon so Kranke
Ladezeiten sondern du kannst einfach
überall hinlaufen mit fast allen Sachen
irgendwie interagieren irgendwie rein
und was ich auch halt geil finde lieber
bevor man jetzt sagt man macht so eine
unfassbar riesige Open World die halt
eine die vielleicht halb so groß aber du
kannst doppelt so viele interagieren
genau
irgendwie hier noch ein größeren Wald
mit rein und blabla die klar die haben
ja schon verboten und sowas ist ja alles
drin aber trotzdem dass man mit einem
hintergehen kann sagen immer diesen
kannst ja alles hier kaputt machen
Du bist direkt drin im Spiel Du bist
direkt drin in der riesigen Map und man
checkt aber auch schon direkt zu Beginn
okay ich habe zwar hier die ganzen
Möglichkeiten kann alles machen aber so
das gibt ja auch voll viele Schlösser
die du aber noch nicht machen kannst
weil du noch nicht die Stufe erreicht
hast dann gibt's irgendwelche Quest wo
du bestimmte Zaubersprüche brauchst also
man hat die ganze Zeit diesen wo man
sieht z.B
Quatsch die mich an ich habe mir ohne
Witz ich habe mir gestern gekauft wegen
dem Spiel was weil weil es ist ja so
also es war es war ja klar dass das
Spiel kommen würde und ich habe mir
gestern einen PS5 gekauft und dann so
jedes Mal wo das Release Datum dann ja
ein bisschen ungewiss war du musst
kämpfen
habe ich dann habe ich gelitten aber
jetzt bin ich einfach ich freue mich
richtig darüber okay ich finde auch für
mich bist ja auf jeden Fall
Leute sitzen sondern wirklich 100% 100%
des Lebens Zaubersprüche kannst du mir
so aufsagen ganz schnell hintereinander
boah was würde ich auch interessieren
nicht so viele glaube ich äh das
Abwechseln immer einen sagen ja gut ich
fange damit an humorer Lumos
nein
in flamare
gib mir jetzt
erstmal das mit Zaubersprüche das
wollten wir mal kurz legac auf der PS5
gespielt und auf der Playstation gibt es
sogar den exklusiven Auftrag
heimgesuchtes Geschäft als Extra Inhalt
zusätzlich zum main-game im Stream hatte
auf dem PC gezockt aber auf der PS5
sieht es durch die 4k Grafik noch mal
deutlich besser aus und durch die Dual
Sense Controller mit dem haptischen
Feedback und den adaptiven triggern
machen die Kämpfe auch richtig Laune
schnell geht es auch die Konsole hat ja
auch eine eingebaute SSD eigentlich
irgendwas erzählen so wie es war
krass auf jeden Fall wir haben gerade
noch mal so die ersten Missionen relativ
viel gespielt und äh war auf jeden Fall
cool paar Leute zu treffen
[Musik]
auf jeden Fall von dem Hogwarts Legacy
Lounge und hier in
das Legacy ist jetzt draußen es hat mir
auf jeden Fall unfassbar viel Spaß
gemacht Euch da alle bei dem Event zu
treffen wir ein bisschen gezockt ein
bisschen gequatscht habt der gerade so
ein bisschen best of von gesehen weitere
Infos findet ihr auf jeden Fall unten in
der Videobeschreibung
eingeschrieben von mir
er lasst einen Daumen hoch unter dem
Video da abonniert meinen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke um alle möglichen
weiteren Videos nicht zu verpassen wir
sehen uns die Tage wieder bei dem neuen
Video und jetzt mir schlecht